I've been recording all day so my voice is tired.
Hello,
hello, hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
I'm tired.
Wait, did I say tired?
Wait, what did I say?
Oh god.
Wait.
I said welcome, not tired, right?
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
My- Sorry.
Team Stummy would like to- What?
Like to apologize for causing you pain.
Oh yeah, I just finished recording something and I only had
like a couple minutes to eat so I went like eating in
Minecraft and now my tummy hurts oh hasn't even been five
minutes yet yeah it's it's it's just one of those days you
have to please wow mega bonk now with 10% more bonk I need
to take my stresses out so we're gonna bonk like no one has
bonked before maybe actually many have bonked what's in the
what's in the in the refrigerator nothing no one is cooking
but I've never played a mega bonk before so I'm excited
microwave the microwave
It's just one of those days.
It's all about the he slash he says.
Poopy.
Is this a moai?
Almost.
Yes, I'm excited to balk.
It's over.
What's over?
Kiara really enjoyed it.
I remember watching Kiara play a little bit.
Hat dog!
Hello, Minto and Ivo's like you.
I wish upon this little Minto no more tummy hurt and many
balks, which are I hope
you guys are doing well um a slight reminder that that um
Saturday I'll be heading off to Japan yeah so first couple
of days while I'm there while I'm adjusting to the jet lag
so I have some stuff that I will be doing um some some cool
things that I will be able to share next week But Portal 2!
Portal 2 playthrough will be uploaded in increments.
I did have to separate the parts.
So it'll be 1 through 4, the first couple of days that I
can't stream.
And then I'll stream some days.
Not every day, I'll do my best.
And then, uh, and then, uh, oh, the second half will be,
like, later on in my trip.
On some other days that I know I can't stream, so.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, they're premiering.
They will be premiering.
Yes, yes.
So it'll be just like a live stream.
You can watch my descendant of madness.
The portal madness.
I do have some madness.
I'll go out to Japan tomorrow!
Excited for the cafe!
Me too!
Thank you!
See you there, hopefully.
Yeah!
Leaving for Japan on Saturday too!
Looking forward to go to the cafe!
Yippee!
Yes!
There's also the Ayami family collabo cafe that Ayami and I
will be Cafe in Akihabara if you are there.
So, yes.
from March 7th to 22nd, I believe.
So a long time.
Minto with hair, Buzz.
I know!
And she didn't post it, but there's another variation of
that picture.
One for maybe the enjoyers of the Megane.
Maybe.
But that will be merch at the cafe.
Yeah.
Yes, yes, yes.
I mean, though, it's my birthday on this Monday.
I wish this year's for you to have a nice trip.
No more tummy horde for you.
Thank you!
Happy early birthday.
Wait, how do I say your name?
Happy birthday!
Yes.
Actually, I have some stuff to record today and tomorrow for
the cafe, so.
Yes, yes, yes.
More stuff.
I was supposed to record it earlier, and then some other
recordings took longer than I thought.
But, yeah.
So that will happen.
I will also be on Ayami's 3D live 3D family concert on her
channel.
I will be gone for a bit, but Minto will be around.
You'll still get Minto content.
At least YouTube did fix the issue about chat yesterday.
I know!
I'm actually quite surprised.
They were very proactive about fixing it and about telling
people that they were working on it.
They told me.
They tweeted at me and they were like, oh, we're working on
it.
Crazy.
Yeah, so it was pretty fast.
Yeah.
They were like, we understand that this is a issue.
No more desu desu!
Kind of a big issue deleting English.
Yeah, you would think.
But honestly, I feel like sometimes YouTube Doesn't care
about The streaming part, you know what I mean?
Like despite there being so many people that use YouTube for
live streaming It feels like they like that's why I was like
kind of shocked that they
handle it I can play balloons while I'm gone
it's like an afterthought yeah yeah which is so crazy
because they like got the people like they they had like
that whole initiative to move twitch streamers over to
YouTube and then didn't do anything silly youtube always
keeping us guessing with their pranks it was funny though i
was seeing everybody having to put like this in the chat it
was pretty cute
but yeah yeah well i don't want to get into a whole
discussion about it because i know we could we could beat
the dead horse about it it is what it is for now hopefully
you know You know, we can only do so much and we can only
fight so much, so yeah.
Felt like good old early 2000s for a short while.
I know everybody was being like, oh This is so kawaii dasu
Well, we will instead of rather than a YouTube blunder we
will think of it fondly as some as a as a nostalgic moment
Yeah, hi Mito, hello Artemis, thank you so much for 16
months, welcome back.
Nostalgic, so nostalgic, desu!
Adding desu to the end of my words, desu!
I do wish that, you know, like in Japanese, kind of those
sort of vocal, how do you, not vocal tics, are they vocal
tics?
Vocal inflections?
are like more common you know than in English
stims?
I don't think it's a vocal is it a vocal stim?
I don't think so I'll miss ending all my messages in
Min-to-kudo!
Thanks, Keppu!
But you know how you have yeah, you have like Nyo and Nyo
and you have Desu!
I mean, Desu is like actual particle but at the same time it
depending you know on the character in the show or whatever
like even peko peko peko da yo yeah i wish it were something
more common in the english language it's so cute though yeah
What's another one?
New and Yor, they're like a Digi-Carrot.
English isn't more in and I'll find out.
Boo!
We have Yanao.
Yanao.
Is Minto partly based off Dejiko.
Is it my ears?
Did somebody say da yo?
Da yo!
In it?
What if one day I just started doing something though?
What would a, I guess a ghost could be like a boo?
Hello boo!
My my boo.
This!
Yeah.
Boo.
Oh no boo!
Okay, I have to go over there boo!
Oh no, I died in
the...
Ugu!
Oh no boo!
Game boo?
Ugu!
Also, I was like talking about, not updates, but like just
stuff that will be happening while I'm away.
March 10th is Minto Day.
Minto no-hi!
Because three can be read as me, and ten can be read as to.
So it's a Minto day.
Not Mario.
We don't care about that guy.
But I do have a special little something that day.
Hopefully, if all goes well.
If not, it might be a little bit later, but I do have a
special little something for you guys.
Min tode!
Shin-so there!
Thank you so much for the check out there!
I think, or something is my desk.
I use it a lot.
Yeah, I guess there are words that, like, people end their
sentences with in English, you know?
But it's not as cute as saying like a...
Meow.
Or new.
Peckle.
Libby Gore, thank you so much for the 5-githard!
I had Bioshock and Berry Berry, Berry, and now we got Booz
in the box.
Of the mega variety.
Also, Minto Day over Mario Day.
Agreed.
That's true hopes.
Narwhal, thank you so much for the 5-githard!
Oh, my Tommy!
I was hoping that me talking with, hold on.
I ate too fast.
You know, when I was a kid, when I was a little wee wisp, my
mom would say, don't eat fruit so fast.
I didn't eat fruit, but my mom would say, don't eat, oh no,
she would say, don't eat so much fruit.
Because it'll give you a stomach ache.
And then, now that I'm a big ghost, I eat as much fruit as I
want.
And it gives me a stomach ache.
She was right.
I'll just eat a bunch.
What's my favorite fruit?
I love so many.
I'm a big raspberry enjoyer, though.
I'll get a little thing of raspberries.
I'll eat the whole thing.
And grapes.
That was the one thing my mom would be like, don't eat all
the grapes.
You're going to get tummy aches.
But she's not here to tell me not to eat them now.
So I do, and then I get a tummy ache.
Raspberry smoochy.
Mmm, hold on, let me eat.
It's...
Mi aminto.
Don't lie.
What am I lying?
What am I saying?
What did I say?
My niece, who was a toddler, got a bad stomach ache from
her.
rapes.
It happens.
No!
I might just be suffering.
I, after the stream, I forced myself to take things off of
my list of stuff to do.
I was like, I can't do any more today.
Really, I think English has way too much slang for hello
that you can't tell if someone is being flirty, friendly,
professional, aggressive, or etc.
without tone for context.
That's why think we are rude.
That's why everybody should just stick to howdy.
Howdy.
It's the overall...
It's friendly.
I don't think it can be flirty.
Actually, it can be.
Howdy.
Howdy, big boy.
Stick to oblivion NPC dialogue.
Those are the most rude people I think I've ever met.
I think so.
Anything can be flirty when you say it like that.
Yeah.
I don't know what he means.
It can be flirty.
How is a greeting flirty?
Hold on.
If you're just like,
How's it going?
Hi.
Hey.
Howdy.
Hey, what you doing, flirt?
Stop flirting.
It's weird.
Not working.
It's how you say it.
But then I feel like it could be done.
That could be the same said for any language, no?
And say it with...
Now say it with a southern or British accent.
Good day.
See?
You can turn anything flirty!
Good day.
Good day, mate.
Oh, the bobby.
That was not a British accent, I know.
Salutation.
Salutations.
Hello.
Hi.
English is funny.
And language is funny, you know.
We should all go back to Ungabunga.
Southern Bell Minto can't hurt you.
How, uh, what's a, what's a southern, oh, howdy.
Howdy.
Howdy, y'all.
Is your flirty voice just being a femme fatale?
straight out of a bond movie.
Well, how else?
How do you flirt?
You could try...
Oh, woo-hoo!
That's...
Like in the Sims!
Oh, woo-hoo!
That's skipping many steps.
You go up to someone and say, Woo-hoo!
Oi, brav.
Probably could even make something random like potato.
Sound flirty, to be fair.
Potato.
There's a video from Letterman of Top 10 Things That Sound
Romantic when spoken by Barry White.
This includes dweeb and big ass ham.
Taters.
Shall we play Mega Bonk?
Sir.
Oh, Oofy.
Wait, what's a...
What does the fox say?
He's a quick on his feet and unnaturally lucky.
He shoots fireballs.
An orangey blessing.
I might need to play as that guy.
He's a sword, man.
He's slow and his armor makes him pretty chunky.
No!
He says, I'm not chunky.
It's all armor.
I got big armor.
Fox is a great starter.
That's what I was thinking.
Seems like there's no bad... I want a big clank.
No way.
That looks like a cowboy robot.
I don't even know where to go, too.
Even though I won $50 in a gravel at work, so here.
Being in the office ate my soul, but I could already feel it
being healed, I cast $50 worth of Stummy Horde to be gone.
Safe travels to you as always and get good rest where you
can.
Also, happy birthday, Griffin Blade.
Happy birthday, Griffin Blade!
Happy birthday!
Oh!
No!
If you want the $50 and the raffle at your work, you need to
keep it!
me no i
cast refund i actually don't think i can give those no no
thank you though thank you very much for sting glitch face
there's no you you know if you want to give anything you
could give like a five dollar you could give a dollar even
oh i could think about yesterday with chat messing up was
the tick-tock.
I mean, don't house your gacha pools recently.
Oh, not good.
I haven't actually been doing many.
Um, so, yeah.
The greech.
This guy is just a skeleton.
Why?
skateboard and he's so small I have to kill 1000 skellies to
get him ogre mega Chad whoa get the damaged tome tool I
don't know what the damage okay let's just play the game
default Fox we're going to the forest baby a green place
full of trees birds and great vibes also everything will try
to kill you So this is my first time playing this game, so
let's...
Hand-tack!
Let's go!
Oh.
Oh, music.
Good.
Oh.
Okay, I'm automatically killing them.
Okay, so it's what?
Yeah.
Oh.
Break the pot!
Oh!
Look at you!
Slashes through multiple enemies.
Evasion tone.
Golden tone.
Does it say what it does?
If I click it?
3D vampire survivors, yeah.
I said, Jordan, thank you!
Forgive me, Minto, for I have been a clown.
I've already played Siege for Snake.
I don't blame you.
I'm, you know, you're...
Yeah, I don't blame you.
Oh, the gold gain.
Sorry, I can't read.
Um, let's do another weapon.
Maybe.
Oh, I have to...
Okay, I need gold.
Wait, can I...
I'm getting money.
I'm getting money now.
Goblin.
Jump.
Ooh, dice.
Gold is in the top left.
Oh, I see it.
I see it now.
I see it.
This game is kind of loud.
Let me know if the audio is too much.
Projectile speed.
Wait, I...
Wait, I do have a projectile speed.
because my fire is technically a projectile, no?
So I guess we can only get...
Find the boss portal.
Okay, we gotta go find that.
I can only get four weapons and two tomes.
Shield tomes!
We should all give two dollars Japan trip gasha punch
fights.
No!
Might want a shield.
We'll do the shield tomes then.
They rise from the ground!
Yes, give me more money.
Boss!
Boss, can I aim with this thing or...
Okay, maybe if I, like, look at it.
Is there anything in the bush?
Oh!
Oh, knockback would be good.
Good plan.
This is connected.
No, it's not!
Certain weapons can aim, but not fireball.
Gosh, thank you.
Also, thank you about the audio.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, the shield.
Oh.
The shield would be good.
I also need to get stronger.
Oh!
Oh, they're fast.
Wait, what is that arrow thingy over there?
Oh, the guy's literally climbing a tree!
Oh, my God.
Oh, I got speed.
Oh, cool.
Oh, nice.
Some gold.
My speed is up, baby.
Wait, where's the boss portal?
Is that what that is over there?
Is there fall damage in this?
Oh, it doesn't seem like it.
Oh, what's this?
Greed, Greed, Greed, Greed Shrine.
Oh, what did that do?
Oh, I just did the difficulty up.
Why is there a Goldie Skelly?
Oh, my God.
What common sword.
Thank you guys for all those over time.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh, there is fall damage.
There is, if you fall far enough.
Got it.
HP tone.
Stay near the pole thing until the bar fills up.
Oh, oh, okay.
Oh, oh, they're coming at me though.
Ah!
Oh, it's hard.
Wait, did it fill up?
The guys are getting really big.
Thank you for the other gacha.
I'm not going to do a bunch of gacha points.
Thank you.
You guys can stop.
I'm not going to do a bunch of gacha points.
I'm not going to do it.
Size makes your sword huge.
Good luck.
Thank you, Earthworm, Jim.
Hmm.
I kind of want to see my thing go huge.
holy cow oh my gosh they have they have shields now they're
stronger what is this oh rare shield tone what is oh oh it's
the microwave oh i need more common items is it like oh jl
josh oh what's this
oh so if i take this is it just a random item Something
about gacha?
$5 not gacha fun.
Unlimited item.
So there's no reason not to take it, right?
Victory or bonk.
Thank you!
Permanent boost.
Oh my gosh.
I keep trying to fill it up, but these guys are really...
You guys are...
Oh my god, they're so fast.
Oh, I could open that.
My luck, when, uh...
Wait, this...
Okay, I gotta find the boss portal.
There's a...
Oh, yo, yo, yo, yo.
Let's do my sword again.
Oh, wait.
We'll do fire staff.
Just kidding.
I support un...
Break apart.
Oh!
Oh, I did it!
Gin plus shield.
Gin size.
8% damage.
duration is that the length of the whatever whatever
not much oh spend it you opening chest not much to use a
gold on okay cool got it
more size okay
let's go back and get this chest
open was that good a coward's cloak boost movement speed
when upon taking damage also 5% movement speed let's go all
right stone golem oh I did it hmm let's do attack speed I
think yeah movement never hurts for sure because I think if
my sword is faster it'll be better right I'm running, I'm
running.
There's a gold there.
Ah!
Wait!
Who is that?
Wait, the stone golem.
Oh, there's just a man standing here.
Talk to a shady guy.
Oh!
Gain two thorns for every 1% armor.
Also gain 10% armor.
There's just a guy standing here.
Increase luck by 2% when opening a chest.
increase chest price by it increases the chest price credit
card is great early is this still early credit card reflect
any incoming damage back to the attacker and gain a short
invulnerability wait why does the mirror sound goaded though
luck is strong okay i'm i'm you know this is my did he just
say idiot did he just call me stupid wait are they He just
called me dumb.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Epic Fire Staff!
Oh, my God.
I think he called me dumb.
Med Kit.
Let's go.
There's a blue Skelly even.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
They're coming from the ceilings.
They're coming from everywhere.
Oh, my God.
I'm trapped.
I can't see anything.
Please.
Oh, God.
Where?
Oh, there he is.
The golem.
Swarm!
This is not the swarm already?
Wait, where are we talking?
Why do we need a swarm is incoming?
I think the swarm is here.
I-I-I-I-I-I-I-I.
Oh.
Shield.
Blue Skelly drops lots of EXP gold.
Skelly drops lots of gold.
Okay, cool.
Good to know.
I-I-I-I.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I'm trapped.
They just won't stop coming.
They don't stop coming.
Epic Scarf.
Deal 50% more damage while airborne.
Oh, shoot.
Firestaff.
I don't know what the difference is.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Um.
Size.
Oh, my God.
holy cow my sword my fire staff did i die oh
maybe him skill issue i'm wow
1336 6,136,922 out of the whole world.
Good first run, honestly?
No kidding.
Thank you.
Good first attempt.
Really?
Was it?
Okay, I believe you.
What's this?
Slurp gloves.
Wait, overpowered.
Wait, big bonk!
Wait, so there's above epic?
Is it like mega epic?
I can't believe Minky.
No, I didn't get mega bonked.
I bonked.
What are you talking about?
Let's try Fox again.
Oh, it's legendary.
I was hoping for like a cooler name, you know.
Oh, I just...
Oh, greed shrine.
Oh, I did this again.
Oh, that's what the shrine...
Oh, I thought it was the temple thing that I...
Oh, this thing.
Oh, magnet.
Oh, this probably attracts like all the stuff on the field,
right?
Okay, understood.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Chunkers.
Chunky rocks that surround me.
Are they good?
The chunkers?
Difficulty makes enemies spawn more and stronger so you can
scale stronger, but it's harder.
Also gives you 25 money.
I'll.
I'll try it.
Oh, I see the bar now that you guys are talking about.
Oh.
Damage to elites.
Power up.
Wait, power multiplier increases the power of power ups.
effect and duration.
Projectile would be good because of my fireball, no?
These are good to get in the beginning.
They're very easy.
More attack.
Look.
Let's go with luck.
Junkers!
Oh, shield would be good, huh?
Silver.
We'll do the shield.
Let's get this guy, let's get, look at my chunk, look at my
chunkies.
They sure are chunking.
We're chunking along.
There's a, there's a, there's a good, there's a gold shield
here.
So what is the boss portal?
I don't think I found that in the last one.
Golden glove.
Earn 50% more gold.
Hockey.
Oh, what's that?
Oh my god, there's slimes!
Oh my god!
Wait, they're kind of cute.
Agility.
Movement speed.
Wait, that's kind of awesome.
Oh, I don't know.
I mean, obviously this one's uncommon, so I get more, right?
Oh.
But it's only uncommon.
Attack cooldown seems goaded.
Yeah, let's go cooldown.
Oh!
Wow!
Whoa!
What is this?
I
would kill you, freeze time!
Breaks after one use.
Jawardo.
Okay, so that kills all the guys around me.
Chonk, chonk, chonk, chonkies, chonkies.
I'm picking up stuff right now.
My guy is just skipping along, he's so hunky-dory, happy.
Your life is easy for a little fox, huh?
You give extra XP, is that what it was?
Let's do my shield.
Chunky-dory!
Oh.
Cool down.
72!
Slippery ring.
Oh my goodness.
Nice.
Is this a portal?
I am the king, Skelly.
Don't take any damage for two minutes.
Wait, that looks like a portal.
I have aura.
And I have gymsauce.
Increased damage.
Oh yeah, babe.
Oh, no.
What a banana.
What does this do?
Why is it red?
Pick up range.
Duration.
Damage.
Banana my beloved.
Oh my gosh, okay I'll go get the banana.
I was gonna go get it anyway, but...
There was a chest behind the tree.
Oh, was there?
I'm gonna do damage.
Chess behind the tree.
Oh, I see it.
I'll grab it first.
Oh, I do not have enough money.
I do not have enough.
Touch the shiny banana.
Oh, I found a hidden banana.
What does it do?
Oh, I got an achievement for it.
For finding the hidden banana.
Oh, oh, oh.
Whoa, whoa, that was close.
Oh, what's this?
I don't think I need it, though, do I?
My health is...
Ah!
The banana is shooting!
The banana is doing a job!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I might win!
Oh my god, oh my god.
That'll be good.
Defeat a mini boss in 25 seconds!
Wait, that was a mini boss?
Wait, thunder mitz.
Upon hitting an enemy, clap their cheeks so hard it
generates a lightning strike.
Epic cooldown.
Oh, banana!
Banana rang!
Projectile speed.
Um...
Okay.
I don't know.
They're all common.
Maybe more chunkers.
Yeah, projectile count.
More projectiles.
Yes.
Wait, so if I spawn this guy...
So I'm guessing I have to spawn him and then...
Oh.
And then I...
Oh, wow, another epic...
Oh, no, sorry.
Rare Tom.
And then I have to beat him and then find my way out of the
level.
Is that kind of the gist going on here?
Oh, there's another one right here.
Upgrade cooled down Tom to level 5.
Oh, the portal's the way out.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I have a lot of gold now.
Hmm.
Maybe a knockback.
After the boss just fight until death.
Oh, okay.
Malai.
I'm gonna do the...
Knockback.
Chest!
Oh, wait!
There's a Malai!
Oh, the swarm is incoming.
Yeah.
You want to do it before the timer ends or you'll die
eventually.
Oh, okay.
Oh, it's 35% chance to apply a stack of bloodmark.
What the hell does that mean?
I'm consulting the Moai.
The Moai shrugs.
A fair and balanced judgment.
He doesn't have shoulders.
So luck seems good in this game, huh?
From what I'm guessing, from what I'm understanding.
Luck is a decent skill to have.
I should probably go back to that magnet.
Maybe there's a magnet around here.
Chunkers, chunkers, chunkers, more chunkies.
Chunkies, chunkies, chunkies.
More chunkies.
Oh, my chunkies are gone.
Oh, yeah.
Attack speed.
It doesn't matter how fast I move if everything else is...
If my attack is faster than everybody else.
Great, thank you.
Oh, I have two.
Oh, they stop.
Very interesting.
Faster, faster, faster.
And look how strong I am now.
Oh, what's this?
I'll do my fire stop.
Rage!
Where'd the swarm?
I thought there was a swarm coming.
What happened to this?
Oh, there's bees now!
Oh my god!
It came and it went.
Oh, epic chunkers.
Oh, yeah, baby!
Banana ring!
The bees, the bees, the bees!
Let's go find another chest.
Oh, wait.
Wasn't there one?
like over here.
I think I missed.
I forgot about it.
Oh, what's this?
Summon the challenge.
Oh, what does that mean?
What does summon the challenge, man?
I'm scared.
I'll think about it.
Tab for... Oh, there's a map?
Oh my god!
Phantom!
That's me!
After evading, deal two times damage, next attack and
temporarily increase attack speed.
Okay.
Well...
Oh, what's she still?
Oh!
Wait, there's a gold pot over here.
I like how, even though time is broken, guys are still
spawning.
Sparky shield!
Gain two thorns for every 1% armor.
What's my armor?
Oh.
Zero.
Oh, big guys, big guys, big guys, big guys, big guys, big
guys, oh, big guys, big guys, big guys.
Oh, what's that down there?
Oh, another Malai.
We can go to him.
I might have a really, I might have a pretty good build, I
think, you guys.
Critical!
Oh, if only I were earlier, right?
What's, a deal?
50% more damage while airborne.
Well, I haven't been jumping so much, so.
Bananas are really good early on.
Yeah, I could tell.
Mmm, feels like a good solid star.
Green?
What's a green?
Oh, what is green?
What's the difference?
I do have two slippery rings.
I could add another.
Two?
Green card.
Yeah, but it says credit card green.
Is there other colors?
There are other credit card colors.
Yeah, oh, maybe we should go summon the guy, huh?
Okay, let's do it.
Let's go summon a guy.
Oot!
Oot, oot, oot, oot, oot, oot, oot, oot, oot, oot, oot, oot,
oot, oot, oot, oot.
Oh, golden scaly!
Nice.
Oh, I cannot afford.
We're catching that air, baby.
Sick air.
Swarming coming.
Oh, uh oh.
Oh.
Little bark.
I think he's a pretty big bark.
Oh!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, no.
God, it's kind of hectic.
Oh, he's tough.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's do my shield.
Maybe I should have summoned with more time, you know?
Golden shield.
Will I be able to do that?
to beat him, I wonder.
Okay, he is taking damage, though.
I can't see!
Oh, he's tanky.
Oh, Lily, I have enough time.
I am attacking him!
I am!
We'll do more attack speed.
Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ah, yeah.
What the heck is that thing?
Oh jeez, ouch!
ouch!
Who the heck is you?
What
the heck is you?
Take more damage when airborne, they said?
Or do more damage when airborne?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Did I take out that one guy?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Evade!
Banana.
We did it!
We took him out!
Whoa!
Complete forest!
Tier 1!
Bro!
Oh my god!
Oh.
Beer!
20% damage at the cost of 5% minus 5% max HP.
Well, I have to take it.
It doesn't give me another choice.
Oh, epic cooldown.
Holy holy.
We'll do a banana.
Epic tome.
Epic fire staff.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, final swarm.
Oh, they're like little ghosts.
They're cute.
Oh, holy cow, my fire.
It's kind of insane.
My fire is kind of insane right now.
Holy cow.
We'll do more shield because it's the final swarm.
Magnet shrine.
Yeah, where was it?
Oh, there it is.
E.
No way.
That was it.
Is there a place that I need to leave?
Like...
Oh, just survive.
Okay, that's my...
list of things to do.
Survive.
Got it.
The boss portal.
Oh, okay.
Go to the portal.
Where?
Oh, it's this way.
I'm going, I'm going.
But I don't want to leave.
Just, yeah.
Oh, there's... Ow!
What is this?
Money!
And this?
Okay.
What do you mean no tier one portal?
What does that, what the heck does that mean?
Holy cow.
What does that mean?
Oh my god.
Leave me alone.
Ah yeah.
Survive the final swarm for 60 seconds.
Holy cow.
Oh my god.
Ouch, oh, oh.
Oh god, they're scary.
Ah!
The portal doesn't work yet.
Okay, I can tell that.
Yeah, I'm understanding that real quickly.
Oh, my God.
Oh, God.
I'm going to die.
Oh, my shield.
My shield is gone.
Is it working out?
Does it work now?
Oh, I almost died.
And then that, it froze time.
Oh my god!
What the hell?
It's so hard, though.
It happened.
Oh, I crit 100 times.
And I also fired 5,000 projectiles.
Those are my two achievements.
I can't keep screaming like this.
My voice is so overused today.
Chunkers!
Oh my god!
I'm just getting pushed around.
like i'm a pinball what the hell i'm just a damn pinball in
this place holy i survived the final swarm for two minutes
oh holy cow mega bonk pinball that was really good it looks
like i got a new guy maybe new record
Ghost.
Survive the final swarm for 60 seconds.
Item Ghost.
I need that.
Bob dead.
Survive the final swarm.
I got...
Oh, I got...
Dead Bob.
Oh, I got Clank!
Uh...
Oh.
The leaderboard.
I'm blocking it.
I am the leaderboard.
Oh my god, I'm on the leaderboard!
Oh, wait.
I thought I was...
I don't know what I thought.
I was like, I'm top 10!
10,000.
100, 100...
I did so well!
Oh,
I can buy.
I'm gonna buy it.
The banana ring was great.
What's this?
Aura.
Oh, hell yeah.
Okay.
Buy weapon revolver.
Wait, do I have that?
No.
Oh.
Quantity.
But what does it do?
You're number one in this stream.
Control to slide.
Use it on inclines.
Oh, thank you.
Top 150K?
Yeah?
You're always number one.
Stop it, guys.
You're acting like my parents.
It's embarrassing.
You're number one more than 100,000 times to honestly.
Thank you.
Oh, tactical glasses.
Ghost!
Oh, I can't buy him.
No!
I missed the ghost.
I got too into buying the weapons.
Okay, we gotta play more so I can get more silver.
Click on the revolver.
Where is it?
Oh.
7,500 enemies.
Oh, I'm at 3,707.
Let's keep playing, baby.
Sir Umphi.
In 1% armor per level.
Should we try him?
You'll always be number one in my heart, Minto.
Sir Umphi!
Why not?
Challenges.
Fly upon taking me... Oh!
Whoa!
I'm not... I've only played one time.
Time to cook.
Shoo!
Come on.
Oh, there's one.
One of these thingies.
I feel the clunk.
You know what I mean?
Look in, shield.
Oh, wow.
I'm skateboarding.
Oh, I used it on the hill.
Just like I was told.
I got it!
Alja!
Seriously?
Knockback.
Hmm.
If you can skate, if you do it after jumping repeatedly, you
gain a lot of speed too.
Number one.
Oh, oh my gosh.
Can I buy you?
30.
Wait, what's this over here?
Oh, it's the shady guy.
Oh.
Oh, hi.
I can't afford anything.
Any more money.
Alright, I gotta kill more guys.
Anything else?
Oh.
I want this pot in here.
No, go away.
Oh, I found the boss portal.
Ouch.
Let's do the cool...
down.
Holy cow.
Do I have enough?
Oh, I have 60.
We found the portal already.
Are the maps very big in this game?
They don't seem humongous, but they don't seem small either.
Composer said this was based on divine bloodline.
I'll take more gold.
Yeah.
Oh, one right here.
I wish to skate up up the hill
Luck More luck please Uncommon sword Damage tone I think
though More Holy cow when did they get Is he just leaving?
Wait come back You can't leave Where are you going?
I missed him.
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
I don't feel so confident with this guy.
Oh my god.
Get me in there.
Get me in here.
I don't feel so confident with Umpfi, you guys.
Oh.
He's a bit tougher.
The aura!
Give me the aura.
Arra!
I paid for it, so of course I want to use it, you know?
How can these guys climb up a wall like that?
Arra is my garlic.
You know what's so funny?
I've never played vampire survivors.
Can I...
No, I'm not getting...
Okay, good.
I was like, I'm not getting any good things.
Shady guy, I'll come back for you.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh, no, no.
Already?
Oh, my god.
What?
Ouch.
Ah, I can't see.
I have no projectile, so I gotta be right on top of him.
Can I hurt himself?
Can he hurt himself?
Wait, lightning bolt.
Let's do this.
Well, health regen is kind of good too, though.
Let's do the damage.
Wait, please.
Yes.
Took that guy out.
Oh!
Oh,
you can eat so much spaghetti.
I've got a...
I can't wait to eat spaghetti.
Also, crits have 14% chance to become mega crits.
Getting plus 15% crit chance to increase a mega...
Huh?
Okay, whatever you say.
Oh, there's a...
Let's do more cooldown.
Oh my god, I keep getting the same things, which I guess is
fine.
Like, stuff stacking is not a bad thing, you know what I
mean?
But, okay.
What else is around here?
Let's go back towards...
Excuse me, excuse me, excuse me.
Oh, swarm incoming.
Wait, mega crit.
Whoa.
More aura.
Oh, oh, my aura.
Oh, my aura.
Dargo, that's gonna be me.
Check the map.
It's hard to read it, though.
I don't...
Especially while I'm playing.
You guys don't think it's hard to read?
We
need more aura.
Jump higher and further.
Whoa!
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Oops.
Spiky shield.
Awesome.
Like, I don't know what these symbols mean.
Check the map.
What does it mean?
What does it do?
Oh, this is a thing.
Oh, and also, what does that do?
Oh, yes.
Give me more cash money, baby.
Oh, oh.
More luck.
Okay, I'll take it.
I can get more jumps.
Red is the boss portal.
blue is the power of beacons oh okay three jumps oh my god
wait that my ouch wait come back
i guess then we should probably
we should probably summon the guy soon though
i'm getting so much gold now wait what is that thing What
are you?
Oh my god, the bush is a boss.
And he's tanky.
Holy shoot.
He does shoot.
Oh, he's a boss.
I thought he was a friend.
Why would I think he's a friend when literally the
description for this place is...
Ouch!
Is everything in the forest is trying to kill you.
That was literally the description.
Everyone dies to the bush at first.
I'll do my best.
Ouch!
More damage!
More aura!
More sword!
More!
sword I wanted to summon the guy Ouch I wanted to I'm trying
to get around the block the rock when he starts shooting at
me You know Oh my god Oh my god Oh my god oh my god Oh my
god oh oh oh oh oh oh
Cool down Oh jump so true You're right Oh Ah, you can shoot
in the air!
Holy!
I want to call the boss, but I'm scared.
The bush is out to give me!
Oh, whoop, whoop, whoop, whoop!
Help!
Swarm!
No, I'm getting caught by a bush.
Please!
Please be kind to me!
Oh, damage.
Oh, okay, I didn't take any damage.
Everybody's coming down, though.
Yeah, yeah, it's a party down here.
It's a party down here.
Who did I kill?
Increase!
Damage!
Oh, my aura.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, he is at 50%.
Oh.
Damage!
Holy cow.
Okay, right after this bush is dead, if I don't die first,
we'll get the boss or something.
Oh, yeah, you can't get me up here, Bozo.
Unless I go back downstairs.
But, you know, I want to kill him, that's why.
We're so close to killing him.
We're so close.
Where'd he go?
He's just a bush.
More damage!
Oh, let's do this.
Hell yeah.
More aura!
I found and defeated the bush!
I got the bush!
I defeated the bush!
A wrench.
Get the damage to him to level 7.
Charge shrine, charge faster.
All right, let's go summon the boss because I only have two
minutes and...
Wait, why am I so slow?
What's happening?
Chunky the terrible!
Ayyyyyyyyy!
Ouch!
I might die.
I'm not very fast.
Okay, Chunky, come on.
I need you to leave me alone.
Ouch!
Okay, Chunky is almost though.
Chunky the terrible.
That guy is terrible.
Oh, we killed him.
We killed Chunky.
Two percent chance to spawn a Borgar!
I'll take it.
What does the Borgar do?
Wait, take that?
Oh, this is huge.
Yeah, baby.
Yeah!
Oh A burger Oh my god, ouch.
I did not see it.
There's so much happening on the screen
What is that?
What's this guy?
Epic aura
Oh more shield!
Wait, I need you to not be up there.
What the hell is this cheating?
My house!
Oh, does burger heal?
Oh my god My health!
Please, burger!
It does, okay, cool.
He's so close.
Oh, I killed a thousand skellies!
I got the guy!
Let's go!
Stop cheating!
I killed him!
Nice.
Now survive, yeah.
Now I must survive.
These guys are scary.
How long do I have to survive for?
Why won't the portal open up?
Oh, Borgler.
Oh, yo, yo, yo.
Level two, not unlocked.
When does it unlock?
Holy cow.
You needed to pick up tier two.
Oh, tier two in the menu.
Oh, I'll see.
How am I supposed to know?
that.
You guys have just been saying tier two.
Okay, okay, okay.
I can survive, maybe.
I will survive!
As long as burgers are dropping, then I know I can survive!
Give me a little tomato and hold the cheese.
I'm not lactose, but I just prefer it not on my burger.
I have one more oil!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my cow, it's pinball time.
Wait, I wonder if I can get some more chests.
Wait, the shady guy.
Excuse me.
Oh no, I'm gonna die here.
I'm gonna die here.
I'm gonna die here for real.
Excuse me.
Just wanted to get to the guy.
Maybe him skill issue?
I did.
We got 13.
Oh, I got the Mega Chad!
And I got Bush!
Margin D, thank you so much for the gifted!
Thank you!
I know, he did just stand there and watch.
Why don't they kill him?
Why are they all going after me?
We got the Skelly.
We got Mega Chad.
Get the damage to him to level 7.
Oh, and Bush.
I want to be that guy.
Oh, I have to buy- the sniper wait I love them what do I
need to get the sniper precision tome to level 10 okay but
right now we can get the ghost right Bob Bob is dead I want
to get him let's try him oh and ghost oh I have one I'm to
one too few team cheese called they want their super chat
back look you can have all the cheese you on your burger why
do you guys care why do you guys care if i want pineapple on
my pizza if i want cheese if i don't want cheese on my
burger why do you care what you think you're getting a bite
of it or something no it's all me so if i want pineapple on
my pizza i'm gonna have pineapple on my pizza and you're not
even gonna get a single you single bite and on my burger
it's all me that's all going into my tummy tum tum and it's
not going into your mouth at all your taste buds are not
even going to taste the cheese not even single bite of my
burger because it's mine
Why are you not giving us a bite?
Because you can get your own Borgor.
A Borgor.
What are these?
Actually, I want to save up for the ghost.
Calcium.
Buy the aura.
Oh my god, you have to have the aura to get Mega Chad.
Thank you for the Borgor.
Valid crash out.
Have it your way.
Next time you possess me, I'm getting fondue.
I like a fondue.
I thought you possessed people to eat.
Yeah?
And it's still me tasting it.
Unless...
Well, okay, I do possess people to eat unless it is like,
um...
What's the word?
Uh...
Offering.
She hates us.
Relax, me, though.
Have a cheeseburger.
I don't want a cheeseburger!
No burger?
Do your best evil laugh and make it cute?
Why don't you say please?
Actually, I'll take the super chat as a please.
I think that's my best evil laugh.
Grilled pineapple rings on burger.
What do I put on my hot dog?
Ketchup?
That's it.
No more Oshikaz.
What do you mean no more Oshikaz?
Chicago's hate me.
Chicago's hate, Chicagoans.
Chicagoans.
Chicago's.
They hate me.
I'm not rubbing my eyes.
Do you see my hands on my eyes?
No, I'm blowing my nose into my shirt.
Chicago Jean, yeah.
This super chat is to prepay the possession tax the next
time you possess me.
Don't forget to pay the tax or I'll get in big trouble.
But you?
What are you going to get in trouble for?
What about pineapple and burger?
I love pineapple and burger.
Actually, I love pineapple so much I would have it on
anything, I think, maybe.
Let's go back to Fox.
Sir Umphi was great, but we're gonna go back to Fox.
Oh, now it's on...
Oh, now it's tier 2!
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I'm on tier 2 now.
Why is Sonic music?
Not complaining?
Positive?
Why?
Evasion.
HP region.
Hmm.
We'll do the evasion.
Oh.
Banana brat!
Oh, Flame Walker.
What do I get?
Evasion.
We'll go full evasion, baby.
They can't evade.
If I'm too slippery for them, they'll never be able to get
me.
Doggoosu, thank you so much, brother.
Super tough.
Mito is a sweet little thing that likes to eat sweet little
things and everything.
Yeah.
The next time you possess me for food, I'm having you make
it your way.
Yeah, I will.
I will and I'll enjoy it.
My way is great.
I promise.
You'll be so delighted.
Uts.
Ow, it's a really...
I like the maps.
They're so fun.
21% elite spawn increase.
Oh.
Yeah, this is a fun game.
It seems good, but I'm scared.
We'll try it.
regret it until i'm like super crazy strong you know and
have mega projectile on my with my weapons and everything or
not you know not just projectile but
go bigger go home oh my so true more elites give more loot
that's what i'm thinking all right size does size affect
what i have right now like my banana when my banana get
bigger kind of.
Um.
Yes?
Oh, they're so fast.
Oh, you're so fast.
Oh, nice.
Ouchy.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, God.
They're strong.
Okay, let's go find another one of these guys.
Oh, I found one.
Oh, I should have...
Oh, okay.
Every time you level up, you can Okay, okay, got it.
Excuse me, what the hell is going on there?
Oh my god, ouch.
Life steal.
What the heck is life steal?
No, no, come back, come back!
Yeah!
It's not about the size of your banana.
It's about the strength of your banana.
We'll do the shield.
Also, this guy down here.
Hello.
Oh, excuse me.
Excuse me, sorry.
Why are you gold?
Can it give me big money?
20% knockback, 10% crit chance.
Power up drop chance.
I think the crit chance is probably the best, yeah.
Oh.
Oh, I don't need it.
More.
I love the music in this game.
It's so good.
Take
them out.
What is these?
Whoa, that one took a while.
Damage.
Oh,
chunky!
I'm gonna do more shield, honestly.
Oh, Chunky!
Oh, you're not so strong this time.
Oh, oh, yeah.
Take him down.
Yeah, he's low HP.
More Borg, okay.
Alright.
This thing doesn't work very well, I think.
Let's go up here.
Wait, I haven't found the boss portal, have I?
I just realized.
But this...
one this area I oh there's a present it's not a mimic is it
that would be too funny
plus one projectile count nice
yippee ghost beefy roaring increased damage by 20 percent
per 100 max hp oh I have that I have that okay
The present is a hat.
Really?
That's so fun?
I love a hat.
Oh my god, you're so fast.
Oh my god.
Power up, drop chance.
I'll do movement speed.
Santa hat.
Oh my god, I have a hat on.
Oh.
Open the present hidden in four.
Nice.
Is the pickup range good in this game?
Difficulty is good?
It helps.
We'll try it then.
I put banana.
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Give me more banana.
Oh, I can already tell it's making a difference.
My banana's kind of epic.
Wow, your banana is so epic.
Electric plug.
Upon taking damage, send out an electric shock.
Okay, doke.
Where is...
Okay.
We gotta go find the thing, don't we?
Alright.
Oh, more fire.
It's...
Oh.
I don't... I don't see it.
So maybe it's the opposite way.
Ouch.
Whoa, these guys are new.
Wait, wait, come back!
Come back!
Please!
Oh, yes, nice.
We got them.
I'll do the extra health because I have the thing that gives
me more damage if I have more health.
I did it.
Whoa.
25 chests.
Am I ever gonna get the ghost?
I ate something.
More arts, please!
Uh...
Where am I?
Where the heck am I?
Let's go down this way.
I gotta find the boss spawn.
Over there.
We haven't really gone up here, I think, is...
Right?
No.
This way?
The map is so confusing.
Where I think I am, I'm not actually.
Oh my goodness.
Excuse me.
Excuse me, big guy.
I'm lost.
So we need to go this way?
I think.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Excuse me.
Can I talk to this mowai over here?
Can I talk to you?
Yes.
No ice.
We'll do more banana rang.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
This area I haven't explored.
Is that an egg?
It looks like an egg.
Okay.
Excuse me, I have an egg to get to.
So sorry.
What is this?
What are they?
What are these guys?
Ah!
Wait!
Ouch!
I'm lost in the sauce a little bit.
Egg is new?
Legendary size, Tom.
Bigger.
Oh, I got the revolver!
I can unlock him!
We beat him, you get them as a hot.
Oh.
I don't even know where they went, I'll be honest.
Guys, I don't know if the portal's around here.
Vice portal?
Yeah, I see more in a bit of a pickle.
Let's try over here.
Portal!
This guy just spawned.
Because he felt like it.
That's fine.
The wind tells you the directions?
Oh my gosh.
The colors of the wind reel.
Nice.
Yeah, we'll get more shield.
Oh, I killed him.
Ghost.
Okay, not too good, not too good.
It's the portal in the only area that I haven't explored
yet.
Lifesteal.
Give me that cash money, baby.
And this.
Away.
I don't know if I'm gonna bank it.
We're not gonna make it!
Ooh, I'll keep going oats though.
I'll have our oats stack.
I don't see any red wind all.
It's sometimes only- I've noticed it earlier, but it only
happens periodically.
Where's the red wind?
Oh, it's those guys again!
Ouch.
Oh, it's only around the portal.
Ah.
If I don't find it, what happens?
What will happen to me?
Dead.
No.
Oh!
Oh, oops.
I didn't realize that would happen so fast.
It must be over here, maybe.
I see the red!
Ouch.
Nice.
Wait, there's a crate here.
What the heck is that?
What the heck is the crate?
What are you?
Oh my god.
Oh the bark.
Wait.
I have to do all this plus the bark.
Oh we're so we're so screwed.
It's over for us.
It's over for us banana bros.
Oh my god.
Oh my god he's so fast.
How is he so fast?
Everyone else is so fast.
Give me the burger!
Banana over.
Revolver.
Burgerlish.
Quests.
I didn't get Bob at all.
Is Ghost any good?
That was an unfortunate end to the run.
That run looked like it was bananas.
Yeah, it could have been a good run.
by calcium is he cute he looks pretty cute
throws bones the bounce off enemy speed builds up over time
but it's half when you take damage also gain damage based on
speed an undead shredder who pulls off the sickest tricks
he's so cute
what's this one oh the key.
Shows, welcome back.
Thank you.
Oh yeah, this quest for extra silver.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
I did find a frog.
I guess not all the...
the frogs there was no in-game map at release imagine how
fun that was to find the boss portal no way all right now we
can buy way more things like a hat the hats are expensive
what the heck ghost yeah baby and revolver
block 500 damage with the armor i assume kill 2,000 enemies
using the sword oh we're you can't see we're so close to
that one I almost got the axe and why the slutty rocket why
she like that precision tone we should try and do that so
that I can so that I can unlock what is it bush yeah my
slutty racket oh clank oh I I can get him now.
Let's buy him, yeah.
I don't know how to pronounce his name.
I don't...
Oh.
Revolver.
Whoa!
Oh my god, his boots!
Wow!
Let's try him.
The music.
Oh, holy!
Oh my god.
I know why they call him Revolver!
Holy cow.
It's kind of annoying picking up everything, huh?
Lightning staff.
Six shots.
So I'm guessing blue means like you get an uncommon, or does
it not matter?
Oh, rare.
Oh.
Let's get the crit chance.
Ouch.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
They're just pretty to be pretty.
Got it.
Oh!
Rude!
I wonder if I should get the sword.
So that I can have something.
Well, maybe we'll get the aura.
We'll aim for aura.
Because I do want something kind of like...
You know?
Color is upgrade rarity.
Yeah, that's what I meant.
Yeah.
He just... he does kind of just shoot anywhere he pleases,
though.
Oh, he could get the chunkers instead.
The precision tome!
I want to get that to 10!
Wait, precision would also be good because he's shooting.
Root and toot and shooting.
Precision would be really good, actually.
Oh, actually, not bad.
I was not paying attention.
That guy is scaling the wall.
Yeah, we're just scaling the wall for funsies now.
I left the chest.
I don't...
Increased damage.
I don't think I could open it.
I didn't have enough money.
Yeah, see, I can't even afford this one.
Yeah, so I know there was a chest over there, but I couldn't
afford it.
Wee!
What is this thing?
Oh, do I need the key?
Is that what that is?
The key item?
Oh, it was free!
Wait, I missed it?
Holy cow.
Get out of my way, please.
Where?
Oh, we're sitting here.
Oh, I see it!
Oh, thank you guys.
Oh, this one!
I- yeah, okay.
I thought you meant the one over there.
see this one all right let's go exploring because i'm afraid
of missing the uh oh bees the bees already the owch the bees
oh shady guy oh ah ah ah protect us bees Ouch.
Oh my gosh.
I should have gotten the chunky rocks.
I don't think I want the banana ring.
I don't know.
Bow is good for crits, is it?
Bow is crazy.
I'll try.
All right.
We're exploring.
Oh, I see the red.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
We found it, the portal!
More luck?
How can I get so much more luck?
If I'm not getting anything else!
Thanks, Gim.
Thank you.
Thank you, Gim.
Crit.
Oh.
Feeling lucky, Minto?
I got...
Oh.
Oh, oh, hi.
Hello.
My HP is kind of bone, so we're gonna do some more.
Sorry.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Hi.
Ow!
I would like to do this.
Oh.
Thank you.
Revolve.
Yeah.
Oh.
Movement speed, baby.
Are thorns any good?
Movement's always good.
That's true.
Precision.
We're gonna just up- crit everything.
Crazy crit.
Ouch.
I ran right into that bee.
Yeah, I hope.
Let's go open some chests.
If I can find any.
Oh, there's one.
And there's a little shrine right next to the...
Yeah, Clank ain't no tank.
40% chance of poison enemies on hit?
Moldy cheese, my beloved!
Is Moldy cheese good?
Oh yeah, we should go back to the Shady dealer.
You're right.
Lady dealer.
Oh.
Projectile.
Does my gun count as a...
But I only have six shots.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, I hear more.
Holy cow.
Wait, oh, ouch, ouch.
Where was that guy?
Ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh no!
I just passed him.
Oh, well, I died anyway.
That's tough being this guy.
Six shots.
More than enough to kill me.
Oh shoot.
That's what he should have done more, right?
Why didn't you shoot harder?
Give me one second.
Uh...
Yay!
I got some art commission for my portal playthrough.
Giving you one second.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh!
Maybe we need to play a Sir Umphi again so we can get some
of these quests, right?
I think.
Chad?
I don't have enough silver.
Have a nice trip, Minto.
Thank you!
Do you guys want to see it?
Hold on, let me show you.
Let me show you the art.
It's so cute.
I just got one of the other pictures, the last picture.
Because I, like, commissioned a couple so that I could,
like, rotate them for the thumbnails.
Whoa!
Biggie.
Look how cute the companion cube!
So cute!
And then...
Oh, it's PNG.
Me and Chell cosplay.
So cute!
Chell did such a great job.
Let's play as oomph again.
We play as sir oomph.
They had to have done that on purpose, right?
Oh, what the heck is this thing?
I've never seen this before.
Boss curse!
What did I do?
What'd you do?
What did it do?
I guess we'll find out.
Ouch!
Ow!
Oh my god.
I just ran right into that guy.
Pony-Tel-Minto, my beloved!
Now you get two barks.
Oh!
Well, I have to try it to figure out what it does.
I have to try things.
You know?
Oh.
We'll do the damage to elites.
Rip.
yeah I might die I might die I might die okay wait there's
more of them why are there wait could I just keep adding
bosses wait why are there three of them you can that's
craziness I'm not that crazy I'm not that crazy.
Oh, I don't have enough money.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I'm gonna jump, baby.
I'm sure their little bark is worse than their little bite.
Woo!
But my jump height.
A backpack?
Oh, my bad.
But, wait, how... Does my sword Do I count as a projectile?
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
This might not be the run, everybody.
But it's fine because...
I'm just here to...
Get the quests.
Swipe.
Oh!
Hey, buddy.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Evade.
Oh!
This is terrible.
I'm jukeing This guy just walked right He was so funny He
was like walking at me And then like turned around to keep
walking at me So funny Oh knockback I think would be good
for it Oh my gosh my health is craziness Ouch Please I'm
doing so terribly I'm sorry I'm not locked in at all LOL
dash, yeah.
LOL, Lamau even.
Oh, wait!
Oh, there was nothing close but...
Oh, just a little bit.
Just... Oh, good good.
If I... I need to...
Like... Oh, I see the boss portal.
Okay.
My aura!
My aura will leave them stunned and speechless.
Oh my god, I didn't know it meant the mini bosses too.
Oh, oh, chunky.
Chunky, it didn't mean what I said earlier about you.
Oh, oh, oh, geez.
Ah, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
We're aura maxing.
Ouch.
I'm gonna die.
Oh, I'm gonna die for real.
Evade.
Why am I not getting healed at all?
Even when I, like, level up.
Is that a thing that you have to, like, unlock or whatever?
Hello, hello, this.
Lamau.
Lamau, this.
This shoe.
Oh, I have no health seal or regen.
Ah, that's what it is.
I wish I could see.
You know what?
Yeah!
Ouch.
Oh, it's so over.
Everybody?
We had a run.
It's so over for me.
That's okay.
I gotta lock in.
We got some silver.
We can try.
What's his name?
No!
I need fa- Okay, never mind.
Just one more.
One more with Sir Umphi.
Please.
Chunkin' bro is giving too meaning to the terrible twos.
Just find more!
This one will be different.
Oh, please ignore me while I break up in these pots.
There's a shady guy.
Why am I now just seeing...
Expensive.
Big pot!
Why am I just now seeing all these, like, things for the
bosses?
Is that water, though?
Oh, yeah, he did have it.
You can eat so much spaghetti.
Alright.
Okay, there's a portal over there, thank goodness.
Oh, my God.
Aiming the dang sword is so annoying.
Life steal!
Okay, we got it.
We got something at least.
We got something.
Ouch.
Why, please.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
Why can I only aim one way?
This sucks.
Ouch.
Oh, please.
I'm trying to hit you.
Oh, thank goodness.
Yeah, I'm going to do the size.
That's what I was going to do.
anyway there we go oh yeah oh yeah yeah kick their butts oh
beacon this is new charging a charge station or charge
shrine will turn it into a healing zone also spawn two extra
charge what the heck let's go do that one let's go goo it
hey Ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
We'll let him leave.
I don't care.
Please, please!
Did I do it?
No, I didn't.
More projected.
Let's do the banana wrang.
I don't think I got it though.
That's okay.
I did not.
That's fine.
We're not like completely obscenely surrounded now.
Oh, yes, we are.
We might make it.
Please.
Yes.
Oh!
It was a mistake!
It was a mistake.
Yes, more damage.
I need more protection.
Rejection, maybe, too.
Oh, what does the swords do?
What did they do again?
I also need more, like, speed.
Because I'm very slow.
Oh, attack speed.
They literally had it.
Oh.
Give me that.
Multi-chase.
Oh, my God.
Oh, chunky.
Ouch, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Woo!
Plus one chance of...
Proc?
What does that mean?
What does it mean?
Oh, activation, like your poison cheese.
Whoa, okay, interesting.
I have like no money.
I could sure use some health right now.
Like a burger.
I could sure use a burger.
I could sure use this guy too.
Sure use some gold.
Oh yeah.
What did that work on?
What did that do?
Did it do anything?
Yes.
More speed!
Trying to get my burger.
Oh, my burger, please!
Ouch!
Can
I get this golden thingy?
Oh, it's warm.
Oh, we're full of health again.
Yahoo!
Oh, not anymore.
We were.
For a brief moment.
The swarm is coming.
Ouch, y'all, y'all, y'all.
The swarm...
Oh, y'all.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, there has to be a way to move in one direction.
I guess if you walked behind you, right?
But...
I'm gonna do damage.
The boon box.
Does it do anything?
Besides...
Um, you know...
What it does.
Which is make the music really loud.
Oh, oh, Jojo.
Don't read chat.
and walk oh oh I blocked it oh we got the other thing
where's the block 500 a certain fee 500 damage I mean we did
a thing we got another achievement yeah baby yeah baby oh oh
I can't afford that can I get to it though ouch ouch ouch Oh
no.
Yes.
Kill you.
Open him.
Read us!
Get distracted!
More cheese!
Got him.
We got his ass!
Holy cow, wait, I'm foreigner.
Where was the...
I saw it, no?
Or was that a different map?
Wait, where was the demon, the spawn, the portal?
Wait.
Was that a different map?
Uh-oh.
Was that the last game?
Oh, it was the last map.
Uh-oh.
Here I was standing over here.
I was like, yeah, we're right next to it.
All comfy like.
Uh-oh.
Right, bro.
Oh, they're flying.
They're scaling walls again.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I can...
What the heck are these guys?
Eww.
Eww!
This is butterfly's word!
Oh!
Let me just scream if you see red wind, okay guys?
Just go.
Red wind!
Oh, ow, geez.
Oh my god, wait, I can see from here.
I can see my house from here.
Moai!
Shady guy!
Ouch.
I didn't think that would.
Wait, there's a moai.
I think I need the health regen.
but moldy cheese stacked three times would be crazy no
cheese about the scratch
more cheese you guys like more cheese all right we'll stack
it we'll stack it
holy I'm not getting out of here oh yes I am I
like that you can get I like that it's not like a like rare
weapons per se but but that it's you can get a rare spawn to
your you know what I mean like a rare pull of the weapon
that you already have I do like that I think that's kind of
fun oh I see it red wind
oh Wait, I went to this chest.
Yeah, like the rare upgrades rather than it being like this.
Oh, shoot.
This weapon is like super rare.
It's kind of fun.
What if I duplicate?
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
Clone it.
What if I have a fourth cheese?
Wait.
Oh, it's making my cheese.
okay that's uh i don't i don't particularly feel um
confident about this oh my gosh
i think i need attack speed more than luck
this could be better but it's not oh we killed him though no
we didn't wait yes we did but i'm gonna die too maybe oh my
god holy cow
we'll do size
moldy cheese doing work oh yeah more region Let's go.
Well, I want to take out this guy.
But I do think I need to spawn the route.
Where did he go?
He's flying.
Literally cheesing.
Oh, he's poisoned.
Wait, it is actually working.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Oh, we got him.
We got him.
The poison was doing big numbers.
Wait, defeat a stage boss in under 30 seconds is the
achievement I just got.
And something else, but I didn't see what it was.
Ah yeah, ah yeah, oh yeah.
Wait, so now I can lead?
Portal time.
Three.
What was three?
Sorry, I'm going too fast.
You can use the portal to go to stage 2.
Wait, fungus.
What's the fungus?
Is this here?
No.
Oh, shady guy 3.
Oh, sure.
I'll try it.
I got the zawarudo or something.
Here we go.
Oh, enter portal.
Oh, stay for about a minute.
Sorry.
That's okay.
I'll do my best.
I'm in the deep forest.
Ooh.
Oh, this ain't no small potatoes no more.
This is big potatoes, I think.
The vibes are off.
Is that what it said?
I'm deciding between movement or...
I think a movement is probably more important.
My guy's really slow.
I have no money.
So is it the same?
Yeah, boss portal here too.
Ghost!
Using an interactable summons ghosts.
Cheese!
More cheese!
I am the ghost!
I'm the one who knocks.
I am the one who cheeses.
Wait, let me... what is that?
What does this do again?
Oh, summon the challenge.
I don't think I did it before.
Oh, I see red wind!
This way.
Red Hat guy!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, wait.
For every 14 units moved.
Summon Bob.
Moved?
Like, killed?
Should we save up for Bob?
Oh my god, these guys are icky.
Nasty.
Crit damage.
Walked.
Oh, like...
Oh!
Okay, okay.
Then I'll save up for him.
Oh, I thought I would make it.
That's okay.
They launched us over to this guy.
Which ain't so bad.
Amy, though, my new schedule made it impossible to catch
you, Lely.
Oh, it's okay.
Can I get a wink for a belated birthday?
Happy birthday, Supertownman!
Happy birthday!
Scraping against the walls will stop all damage.
Oh, so that's what happened.
Okay, cool.
Oh, we're doing okay.
Movement speed.
We're saving up for a ball.
Oh, big guy, big guy.
Oh, nice, nice.
This is huge.
No, wait, come back!
We'll get him, we'll get his ass.
We'll get his ass.
Oh, why can you climb the walls?
Ouch.
Chunky.
Chunky the terrible.
I think we have enough to get Bob now, maybe.
Let's go get him.
I think it was 600 something, something.
How
to...
Break this.
Ah.
Oh!
Excuse me.
How can I get more gold?
Wow, the poison's going crazy.
I know I said it.
I don't care.
But...
Swarm.
No, I want to get Bob before we swarm.
Please, let me get Bob.
Oh, we have another Wait, where did he go?
He's this way.
There is this way!
This way!
Bob!
Is that the power of Bob?
Oh, chest.
LOL this.
Kill 5,000 enemies as Sir Umphi.
And complete 20 quests!
making big bucks now.
Let's go to the
thing.
Yes!
Bob.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Oh, we found it.
It's right here.
Wait, I could get more cheese.
More cheese.
Oh, my gosh.
Size.
More cheese, please.
My cheese, my cheese, my cheese, my cheese, my cheese.
Clone my cheese, please.
Do you guys think I should activate the boss?
Just yet?
Too early.
Okay.
Wait about two minutes.
Okay, okay.
Oh, break 20 pots in a single run.
I guess I wasn't breaking that many pots, huh?
Oops.
Make more cheese.
Oh, flowers.
Boost movement speed upon taking damage.
More crit damage.
I want to open this thing.
I wish I had it.
The key.
You know.
Ah.
Huey cloak.
You would say that.
Whoa, big damage.
5.69 noise.
The cage.
I
wonder if there's anything else I can get before we...
There's a chest over here.
coming.
There's two chests here.
There's a yellow hat guy.
Where was he?
Wow.
I get healed.
Holy cow.
Oh, give me out of there.
Give me out of there.
East.
Am I facing north?
Oh, I see what.
I see there's a thing there.
That's a blue hat.
I do not see a yellow hat.
I think I gotta go get the guy, though.
I think I gotta go.
Oh, geez.
You're where Bob was.
Oh, okay.
Is it like this way?
Will I be able...
Oh, I can maybe afford something now.
Oh, I see him, I see him!
Okay, then we'll summon.
I can't afford anything.
Okay, it's fine.
We gotta go summon the boss.
Stone Golem, where did you come from?
Uh-oh, we're gonna be fighting both of them at the same
time!
Chad Bork!
Ah!
So I'm guessing I have to be on tier 3.
Oh no!
I jumped right into him!
I was gonna say I have to be tier...
I have to be playing tier 3 to get to a third level.
Ah!
That happened so fast!
I didn't even get to...
Yeah, I jumped right into him.
That's okay though.
I've ranked up.
And look how many quests we did!
That was a great run!
If you had to organize a VTuber performed stage play of
MGS1, who would you cast as each character?
Okay, I do not have enough time to answer that question.
But...
Yeah, hello, super off topic, but popped in to say, I
learned mint likes to adore, and that added to the Indiana
Jones fan.
Makes her the bestest ever.
Now all she's missing is being a Thomas and friends fan.
like Thomas the tank engine oh my gosh that reminds me I
went to I went to get some some snacks for Vicky to try when
I see her and I was wearing a Miffy shirt and the guy at the
register was just like that's a Miffy shirt and I was like
yeah I love Miffy and he was just like do you know do you do
you do like Miffy and friends or Miffy's big adventure and I
was like oh well I've only you know see Miffy's big
adventure.
He was just like, yeah, well, you should watch Miffy and his
friends because it's much quieter than Miffy's big
adventure.
And I was like, oh, okay.
He was like, yeah, the other, Miffy's big adventure is too
loud.
And I was like,
okay.
Cool.
Thank you.
It was so sweet, though.
I was just like, oh my gosh.
Somebody commenting on my Miffy.
I think it's because like you know Miffy it seems very and
then we were like talking about Miffy's design and I was
like yeah Miffy is so iconic like but so simple like you can
see Miffy and immediately know that it's Miffy huge Miffy's
fan spot I know right and relatable peace and quiet enjoyer
I think like Miffy kind of exudes that type of energy right
so you imagine more like of a quiet atmosphere but I was
like dang this guy is like really and I was trying to you
know not to be mean but I was like on a time limit so I was
trying to leave and also it was there was a long line and I
was just like thank you thank you I'm glad you I'm glad we
could talk about Miffy thank you and he was just like still
talking about Miffy and I was like oh my god it was so sweet
but I had to go I've never met someone that, like, you know,
would talk about Miffy with me.
I don't think it was a Riz attempt.
No, the man only wanted to talk about Miffy.
It was not any attempt to get to know me.
No, no.
The guy was really into Miffy.
Which I enjoy even more.
Just conversation this.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, no Riz all Miffy.
Only Miffy Riz.
Riz-Riz-ing Miffy.
Yeah, only eyes for Miffy based.
I agree, I agree.
But, hey, learn about Miffy and you could have a
conversation with somebody.
Men are more attractive when they talk about their special
interests.
It was really cute though.
I was like, I was like, wow, like this was such a nice
little conversation about Miffy.
Like, I don't get to talk about Miffy so much, but I was
wearing my Miffy, I just chose to wear my Miffy sweater, and
then Miffy, talk.
Miffy Rizz is niche, but very powerful.
It was so nice.
Shop?
What's this?
Oh, increased silver.
Oh!
And my...
Agus.
Sir, my eyes are up here moment, but he's just staring at
the Miffy sweater.
It was so cute.
He was like, he like pointed and he was like, that's Miffy.
I was like, Miffy!
You like Miffy!
You know Miffy!
Increased silver is great early on.
I will look into it.
Let's see what we got.
Oh, whoops.
Unlocks.
Oh wait, actually let's grab our quests real quick first.
Nice.
What's here?
Bloody Tome.
Armor Tome.
XP Tome.
Ooh.
And the hat.
Oh.
Boss Buster.
That seems kind of fun.
xp tomes high tier honestly i mean it's yeah it's by it
seems it seems good right what's this one demonic blade
but you guys i'm sorry i would go i would go for chad but we
might have to go for him next time because i have quite a
bit things to do i hope you don't mind if it's a bit of a
shorter stream I'm sorry.
Tomorrow will be mine sweeper.
It's getting late.
Yeah, I have some stuff I need to finish up, too.
So, thank you, thank you, thank you for the stream today.
Thank you, thank you.
I was heading out to Night Meantau.
Good night.
Yay.
So, I will play this while I'm away, though.
So, expect some in the upcoming weeks.
Week.
Thank you so much for the fun get there!
Thank you!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you, Minto.
Thank you guys!
Thanks for hanging out.
It was so much fun.
Wait, this game is crazy.
It's so much fun, though.
Honestly, I kind of want to just buy all of these things,
no?
But the less stuff you buy, the more you can kind of curate
your poles.
You know what I mean?
Wait, I need that!
After evading, deal two times damage next attack.
I need that, that's me!
I am the Phantom Shroud.
Specialized, yeah!
But, um, I'll see you when I see you next!
Otsumito!
Otsumito, Otsumito!
Thank you guys so much!
Oh god!
Thank you so much for the peek!
Oh, you're able to get some stuff done quickly!
Get, get, good rest.
And I hope the tummy hort...
The tummy hort is gone.
I had...
It is now replaced with tummy fun.
Because I had fun.
Yeah.
Tommy hort has been cured.
Hot dog indeed.
Thanks, Troy Purchase.
Yeah.
Otamito, everybody.
Eat that ashy.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
Have a good time, zone.
Sorry, I can't stick around and chat some more or stream
some more.
more i'm sorry but um probably while i'm gone too we'll do
some like zatsu streams and stuff so uh it'll be a little
more chill for the next upcoming weeks and all so i thank
you for your patience while my brain is scattered and um my
my spirit is overworked hard worker me so inspiring No, no,
no.
Okay, I've said Otsuminto and I'm sorry so many times now.
So I go, Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
See you, bye-bye.